[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend in allen Fest zum Rücktritt
entschlossen sein aber mit der
Bekanntgabe des Rücktritts noch warten
wollen das funktioniert in der Politik
selten heute Abend kommt gleich eine
ganze Reihe von Medienberichten zuerst
in der Bild-Zeitung dass die
bundesverteidigungsministerin
zurücktreten wolle dass Christine
Lambrecht das aber erst am Montag dann
selbst bekannt geben wolle sollte das so
stimmen dann hat es nicht geklappt im
Kanzleramt soll schon die Suche laufen
nach einer Nachfolge der Tag der
bundesverteidigungsministerin offenbar
einer ihrer letzten im Amt jetzt von
Andreas
der Tag an dem Christine Lambrecht wohl
aufgibt beginnt gut erst einen Kaffee
dann die Fraktion die
Verteidigungsministerin kommt mit
bundeswehrtasche über der Schulter die
kleine Rede die sie gleich halten wird
werden Abgeordnete als eine ihrer
besseren bezeichnen als gute Rede aber
nichts macht ihre schlechteste Rede weg
damit verbunden waren für mich ganz
viele
besondere Eindrücke die ich gewinnen
konnte
interessanten tollen Menschen als
Christine Lambrecht gestern im
sächsischen Marienberg das
Panzerbataillon 371 besucht kann sie zum
ersten Mal nach dem seltsamen Silvester
Video gefragt werden eine richtige
Antwort gibt sie nicht also erstmal
wünsche ich Ihnen auch heute alles alles
Gute fürs neue Jahr und ich hoffe dass
es im Interesse von uns allen etwas
friedvoller werden wird als das letzte
und daneben kümmere ich mich um die
ernsten Herausforderungen in dieser Zeit
die ernsten Herausforderungen dieser
Zeit hat Ministerin Lambrecht nicht
immer bewältigt zu wenig Fortschritte
bei der Verwendung des Sondervermögens
zu wenig Munition manchmal zu wenig
Gefühl für die Truppe das letzte
versagen wird heute geklärt warum waren
bei einer Schießübung alle 18
Schützenpanzer Puma ausgefallen es lag
nicht nur an der Industrie und nicht nur
an den Soldaten
wir wissen genauer dass es Probleme bei
der Abstimmung gibt
unterschiedlichsten Bereich zwischen der
Truppe zwischen der Industrie zur
Logistik dass wir da deutlich besser
werden einiges von der Kritik die
Lambrecht einstecken musste galt
eigentlich dem Bundeskanzler das
Deutschland dass die Kanzlerpartei SPD
der Ukraine zu langsam und zu
leidenschaftslos helfe der dauervorwurf
im In- und Ausland im polnischen
Fernsehen z.B heute vom
Regierungssprecher
die Deutschen haben ihre Entscheidungen
bisher immer nur Schritt für Schritt
geändert und immer nur unter
internationalem Druck polnischem Druck
moralischem Druck es gibt nichts was
unveränderlich ist nichts was
internationaler Druck nicht ändern kann
und solchen Druck wollen wir erzeugen
es brennt heute Nacht noch Licht im
Verteidigungsministerium wo der Druck
auf Christine Lamprecht wohl zu hoch war
und tun das Nachdenken über eine
Nachfolger beginnt
ja fragen wir noch mal nach in Berlin
bayerische guten Abend wie geht es jetzt
tatsächlich weiter mit Christine
Lambrecht was kannst du uns dazu sagen
also alle Stellen die sich dazu
offiziell äußern könnten die Hüllen sich
heute Abend in Schweigen auch auf
Nachfrage über man muss doch sagen dass
bei einer solchen Häufung von Hinweisen
die dann wieder aus dem Kanzleramt noch
aus der SPD-Parteispitze dementiert
werden ist eigentlich undenkbar ist dass
sich die Ministerin noch lange im Amt
hält denn ihre Autorität wäre wenn sie
bleiben würde massiv untergraben das ist
in jedem Ministeramt schon problematisch
aber im Bundesverteidigungsministerium
in Kriegszeiten natürlich ganz besonders
dass wir heute nur auf Schweigen stoßen
das könnte damit zusammenhängen dass die
Nachfolge noch nicht geregelt ist wenn
dann schon fest steht dass die
Ministerin zurücktreten möchte dass muss
ja einen nahtlosen Übergang geben und
dadurch halten sich natürlich hier jetzt
auch noch die Gerüchte werden Nachfolger
werden könnte das wird spannend werden
denn normalerweise werden Minister durch
die Parteivorsitzende benannt in diesem
Fall ist das unter anderem auch Lars
Klingbeil von der SPD und dessen Name
ist in der langen Riege derjenigen die
hier gehandelt werden auch im Spiel
schon gut wenn es so kommt ist das dann
ein eigener Entschluss von Lamprecht
gewesen oder Ansage des Kanzlers oder
woran wird es dann überhaupt gelegen
haben also wenn sie bekannt gibt dass
sie aus eigenen Stücken geht dann nimmt
sie dem Kanzler auf jeden Fall eine Last
von den Schultern und sie erspart ihm
unbequeme Fragen denn bei aller Kritik
die in den letzten Monaten auf sie
eingehagelt ist hat er sie doch
weitestgehend unterstützt zum Teil durch
seine Sprecher zum Teil aber auch
persönlich er hat sie vor gar nicht
allzu langer Zeit noch eine erstklassige
Verteidigungsministerin genannt und dann
müsste er sich die Frage gefallen lassen
warum nimmt er sie dann jetzt aus dem
Amt wenn aktuell in diesen letzten Tagen
keine weitere Verfehlung vorgelegen hat
warum jetzt erst die Entscheidung hat er
dazu lange gezögert ist er da ist er da
nicht entschieden genug vorgegangen das
würde ihm erspart bleiben wenn eben die
Ministerin selber zurücktreten wird
erfahren werden wir es aber erst wenn
die offizielle Erklärung kommt
für diese Hintergründe heute Abend live
aus Berlin der
CDU-Außenpolitiker Roderich Kiesewetter
reagiert auf die Meldungen über einen
möglichen Rücktritt der
Verteidigungsministerin eher
zurückhaltend die Bundeswehr verdient
eine ordentliche Führung die weiß was
sie an der Bundeswehr hat die den
Kanzler gut berät die sehr gut mit der
Rüstungsindustrie zusammenarbeitet auch
Forderungen stellt und deshalb wäre ein
Rücktritt zunächst ein Fehler
dahingehend weil die Bundeswehr eine
klare Führung braucht und es ist in
dieser Kriegszeit sehr schwer jemanden
einfach auszuwechseln
das ganze Interview können sie nachher
bei uns sehen im heute journal Update
und wir bleiben noch einen Moment bei
der Verteidigungspolitik die
Bundesregierung die ja nicht nur über
mögliche deutsche leopardlieferungen an
die Ukraine entscheiden muss sondern
auch den Verbündeten grünes Licht geben
wenn die ihre Kampfpanzer aus deutscher
Produktion weitergeben hat er sicherlich
auch das im Blick das hier nämlich die
Haltung der Deutschen und die ist nicht
eindeutig aktuelles ZDF Politbarometer
von heute läuft übrigens gleich nach uns
hier gucken wir kurz drauf soll
Deutschland Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 an die
Ukraine liefern die Antwort 42% sagen ja
46% sagen nein
auf der anderen Seite kommt das bitten
Flehen fordern aus der Ukraine natürlich
auch in Berlin an unsere Porter Tim
Kröger hat im Osten der Ukraine Soldaten
getroffen die irgendwie versuchen ihr
veraltetes Material in Schuss zu halten
was sie zu den Aussichten auf Leopard 2
sagen ist klar
umso näher die Front hier im Don was ist
desto sichtbarer wird der Krieg
Militärfahrzeuge überall darunter alte
sowjetische Panzer viele gehen kaputt in
den heftigen Kämpfen mit den russischen
Streitkräften repariert und instand
gesetzt werden sie unter freiem Himmel
irgendwo im Hinterland
diese Maschine wurde aus Solidar
evakuiert während des Beschusses erzählt
uns kostiantin der Leiter des Bataillons
man kann sehen dass sowjetische Technik
nicht mehr fähig ist der modernen
technikwiderstand zu leisten den neuen
Kalibern
an drei der Ingenieur ist gerade dabei
die 780 PS Maschine eines alten
Kampfpanzers aus der Sowjet Zeit
auszutauschen oft aber fehlen
Ersatzteile der Verschleiß an der Front
ist enorm Improvisation ist dann der
Tagesordnung wenn wir nicht genug
Ersatzteile haben dann schlachten wir
die Trophäen aus die wir erbeuten
bis zur Erschöpfung versuchen Sie die
alten Panzer am Laufen zu halten sie
brauchen dringend Nachschub neue
Kampfpanzer den Leopard etwa sagen sie
vielleicht kommen Spezialisten aus ihrem
Land und erklären uns wie man damit
umgeht wenn wir das wissen dann werden
wir auch damit kämpfen
sie wollen wieder in die Offensive gehen
Städte und Dörfer befreien und den Krieg
beenden
ja und die aktuelle Lage in der Ukraine
aussieht das hast du jetzt im Blick
Hannah nach tagelang schweren Kämpfen um
die Kleinstadt Solidar im Osten der
Ukraine hat das russische
Verteidigungsministerium die
vollständige Eroberung der Stadt
verkündet hier wieder sprach den Angaben
Moskau Präsident selensky sagte am Abend
dass die Kämpfe weiter andauern nach
zahlreichen Rückschlägen in den
vergangenen Monaten wäre die Einnahme
der Stadt ein wichtiger Erfolg für
Russland ein Ministeriumssprecher
betonte die große Bedeutung für die
russische Offensive im Gebiet und jetzt
die Räumung des braunkohleortes
lützerath neigt sich dem Ende zu die
Polizei räumt heute das räumte heute das
letzte noch besetzte Gebäude neben
einigen verbliebenen Aktivisten in
Baumhäusern halten sich jedoch weiterhin
zwei Menschen in einem unterirdischen
Tunnelsystem auf deren Bergung sollen
Spezialkräfte von Feuerwehr und THW
übernehmen zur Unterstützung der
Proteste traf die schwedische
klimaaktivistin Thunberg in Lutzerath
ein morgen will sie dort an einer
Großdemonstration teilnehmen
die Führungsspitze der CDU ist am Abend
zu einer Klausurtagung in Weimar
zusammengekommen dabei geht es laut
Parteichef märz unter anderem darum dass
die CDU ihre wirtschaftspolitische
Kompetenz wieder zurückgewinnt
Wirtschaft Energie und Klima müssten als
Einheit betrachtet werden erklärte märz
die Partei werde sich bei dem
zweitägigen Treffen im zentralen
politischen Fragen neue positionieren
und die Bundestagsfraktion der Linken
hat ihre Klausurtagung heute bereits
beendet und sich einiges vorgenommen
nach einer Reihe von Wahlniederlagen und
Personalquerelen will sich die Fraktion
wieder mehr auf ihr Kernthema soziale
Gerechtigkeit konzentrieren wegen der
Preissteigerungen im Energiebereich
fordert DIE LINKE zusätzliche
Entlastungen für Menschen mit kleinen
Einkommen und will Vermögen höher
besteuern und eins bleibt die Partei
dagegen beim Thema Russland Sanktionen
im Norden von Litauen ist es laut
Medienberichten zu einer Explosion an
einer Gaspipeline gekommen es gebe
allerdings keine unmittelbaren Hinweise
auf einen Angriff sagte der litauische
Betreiber die Ermittlungen zu Ursache
laufen die Flammen sollen bis zu 50 m
hoch gewesen sein die Gaszufuhr wurde
sofort unterbrochen laut dem litauischen
Fernsehen sind die Flammen mittlerweile
erloschen verletzt wurde nach bisherigen
Angaben niemand
im europäischen Vergleich ist
Deutschland ein Nachzügler um uns herum
fühlt es sich ja schon viel länger so an
als könne Corona tatsächlich Geschichte
sein jetzt zieht auch dieses Land nach
die letzte für viele täglich sichtbare
Maßnahme zur Eindämmung der Pandemie
wird auch bei uns aufgehoben im
öffentlichen Fernverkehr gibt es ab 2
Februar keine maskenpflicht mehr
Eigenverantwortung und Freiwilligkeit
das sind die beiden Schlagworte die
heute überraschenderweise von einem
kommen der in der Vergangenheit eher auf
Vorschrift und Warnung setzte dem
Bundesgesundheitsminister nämlich Frank
Buchwald berichtet
die Einladung kam kurzfristig auf die
Nachricht aber haben viele lange
gewartet Karl Lauterbach der sorgenvolle
verkündet das Ende der maskenpflicht
zumindest im Fernverkehr die uns
beratenden experten gehen nicht mehr
davon aus dass es noch mal zu einer
großen zu einer schweren winterwelle
kommen wird es ist zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt auch nicht abzusehen das
besonders gefährliche Varianten uns in
den nächsten Wochen und Monaten noch
erreichen könnten deshalb so der
Minister könne man nun etwas mehr
Eigenverantwortung Wagen die FDP hört
sowas gern ein Wegfall der maskenpflicht
heißt ja nicht dass man keine Maske mehr
tragen darf sondern dass man selbst sein
eigenes Risiko beurteilt und
entsprechend handelt maskenpflicht kaum
eine Entscheidung der corona-politik hat
solche Kontroversen ausgelöst erbitterte
Demonstrationen im ersten corona-sommer
meist sogleich von der Polizei aufgelöst
weil eben keiner eine Maske trug
umstritten lange aber der einzige Schutz
gegen das Virus
irgendwann waren dann fast alle geimpft
oder genesen Karl Lauterbach aber blieb
seine Mundschutz treu selbst im Kabinett
war der Minister zum Schluss der letzte
Maskenmann stumme Botschaft Corona
bleibt gefährlich als Pandemie Papst
Christian Drosten von der Charité ein
Interview gab das nach Entwarnung Klang
atmeten viele auf nun jedoch korrigiert
er er können nur erklären dass wir
demnächst in ein paar Monaten sagen
werden im Nachhinein betrachtet war das
die erste endemische Welle dieses Virus
und damit ist die Pandemie vorbei
ganz so entschieden klingt das zwar
nicht mehr die Erleichterung über das
Ende der maskenpflicht trotzdem groß und
lange überfällig sagt die Opposition ich
habe manchmal den Eindruck wir haben uns
so ein bisschen daran gewöhnt es gibt
eben Maßnahmen und es wird gar nicht
mehr hinterfragt ob überhaupt noch die
Voraussetzungen für die
Aufrechterhaltung dieser Maßnahmen
gegeben sind wir reden hier von
Grundrechtseingriffe würden und da geht
es darum wenn die Voraussetzung nicht
vorliegen dann müssen die Maßnahmen
sofort abgeschafft werden auch die
Länder atmen auf Hamburg und NRW haben
das Ende der maskenpflicht im Nahverkehr
für ersten Februar angekündigt Bremen
Hessen Rheinland-Pfalz das Saarland und
Niedersachsen Folgen haben am 2 Bayern
Sachsen-Anhalt und Schleswig-Holstein
haben sie bereits abgeschafft die
anderen Bundesländer hatten ihr Ende
schon vor geraumer Zeit in Aussicht
gestellt
so ist Corona wohl noch nicht vorbei
leben mit dem Virus aber wird Alltag
Notmaßnahmen unnötig und Karl Lauterbach
der sorgenvolle kann sich nun wieder um
die Krankenkassen kümmern
die virologin Ulrike protza ist bei uns
Frau Professorin guten Abend und vielen
Dank dass Sie zu so später Stunde bei
uns sind
guten Abend ist das heute das sichtbare
Signal dass wir kovid wirklich hinter
uns lassen können
ganz 100% werden wir es vermutlich nie
hinter uns lassen können weil das Virus
einfach bei uns bleiben wird aber es ist
schon ein Zeichen dass die Maßnahmen
jetzt irgendwo wieder vereinheitlicht
werden das hat wenig Sinn gemacht im
Nahverkehr keine Masken zu tragen in
Flugzeugen keine Masken aber im
zugmasken ich glaube das sollte man
schon einheitlich vorgehen und das ist
jetzt dann wieder gewährleistet
abgesehen von der Einheitlichkeit ist es
aus ihrer Sicht vertretbar dass die
Allgemeinheit aufhört sich Pflichten zu
unterwerfen um die vulnerablen zu
schützen das war ja in der Essenz mal
die Idee dieser maskenpflicht
absolut und das ist es natürlich
weiterhin wir haben wohl nachable Teile
der Bevölkerung vor allem die älteren
Menschen und auf die sollte man
weiterhin Rücksicht nehmen das heißt
wenn ich eine Erkältung habe wenn ich
Symptome habe und trotzdem in die U-Bahn
steigen muss oder in den Zug steigen
muss dann sollte ich natürlich eine
Maske tragen und wenn irgendwo in meiner
Nähe jemand ist und der hat eine
Gefährdung dann ist es so ein Art der
Höflichkeit auch eine Maske zu tragen
aber die rechtliche Grundlage eine für
eine Pflicht ist vermutlich einfach
nicht mehr gegeben jetzt gibt's aber
gleichzeitig natürlich Nachrichten aus
China die immer noch aufhorchen lassen
wie hoch ist denn aus ihrer Sicht die
Gefahr dass wir noch mal irgendwann
wieder zurückkehren werden zu lauter
neuen alten Maßnahmen walko wird mit
Macht zurückkehrt
ich glaube nicht dass China jetzt für
uns da wirklich eine neue Bedrohung
darstellt die Situation in China ist
kritisch aber das ist ein Problem was
jetzt wirklich die Chinesen haben und
vor allem eben haben werden wenn das
ganze jetzt von den Städten aufs Land
geht wo die Gesundheitsversorgung
einfach nicht so gut ist und wo viele
ältere Menschen leben die zurückgekehrt
sind in ihre Heimatdörfer und eben nicht
mehr in den großen Städten leben und das
ist menschlich schon für mich ein Drama
was da sich abspielt das auf jeden Fall
Frau Professorin der Punkt an dem wir
jetzt im Moment sind ist das auch eine
Chance mehr Ressourcen zu verwenden auf
Forschung und Therapie gerade von
lungenkovit
ich glaube das ist eine Chance und das
ist absolut notwendig denn wir verstehen
ja leider immer noch nicht gut genug was
verursacht long coved und wir haben
keine wirklich guten
Behandlungsmöglichkeiten in der Hand und
es brauchen wir natürlich weil durch die
vielen Infektionen ist einfach schon
viele Menschen betrifft
wenn wir diese schrecklichen drei Jahre
Pandemie jetzt mal Revue passieren
lassen an diesem heutigen Abend da haben
wir viel Chaos gesehen auch viele
Entscheidungen in der Politik die man
heute anders treffen müsste was haben
wir aus ihrer Sicht gelernt
ich glaube schon dass wir einiges
gelernt haben wie man mit so einer
Pandemie umgehen kann wir haben uns in
Deutschland und das muss man ganz
ehrlich sagen eigentlich ziemlich gut
geschlagen auch im Vergleich zu anderen
Ländern sicherlich deutlich besser als
zum Beispiel jetzt die Amerikaner wenn
man das mal als Beispiel nimmt aber es
gibt sicherlich Dinge die würden wir
heute nicht mehr so machen
Einschränkungen in den Schulen würde man
sicherlich vorsichtiger machen aber ob
man wirklich besser da steht nach den
drei Jahren das weiß ich nicht denn wenn
eine neue Pandemie kommt dann ist es
unglaublich wichtig dass man eine gute
internationale Kommunikation hat und die
in der momentanen politischen Situation
sehe ich ehrlich gesagt als schlechter
an als sie vor drei Jahren war das heißt
wenn jetzt ein neuer infektions Erreger
kommt und diese internationale
Kommunikation funktioniert nicht und man
kann nicht schnell reagieren ist das
natürlich einfach keine gute Situation
da muss man sicherlich wieder dran
arbeiten und was müssen wir alle jetzt
ganz damit tun jenseits von Corona um
einfach besser aufgestellt zu sein
sollte Gott bewahre noch mal so ein
Virus kommen
das wird vermutlich irgendwann kommen
und dann ist es eine Frage wie schnell
bemerken wir das und wie schnell können
wir es eindämmen und wenn die
internationale Kommunikation gut ist und
wenn die Strukturen da sind dass man
einfach auch schnell und konsequent
reagieren kann dann wird das
funktionieren nur die Strukturen können
wir intern aufbauen und die haben wir
glaube ich auch in Deutschland sehr sehr
gut aufgebaut da gibt es inzwischen
Netzwerke da gibt es
Kommunikationsstrukturen da gibt es
Gremien die sich vorbereiten aber ob das
auf der internationalen Ebene dann
wirklich so gut klappt das ist glaube
ich eher das Problem hier wenn man nur
am Beispiel China sieht wie wenig die im
Moment bereit sind zu kommunizieren das
ist einfach traurig und ist in der
Hinsicht auch ein Problem du musst die
Welt noch einiges tun jenseits der
maskenpflicht die Virologe in Ulrike
protza vor Professoren ganz herzlichen
Dank dass Sie heute Abend bei uns waren
gerne
so und jetzt Hannah und noch ein Thema
bei dem wir aktuell mal kurz durchatmen
können trotz aller Krisen hat sich die
Wirtschaft in Deutschland 2022 robuster
gezeigt als erwartet das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt legte um 1,9% zu
und entgegen aller Befürchtungen kam es
in den letzten drei Monaten des Jahres
laut Schätzungen auch zu keiner
Rezession sondern zu einer starken
Nation der Wirtschaftsleistung das
teilte das Statistische Bundesamt mit
größter Wachstumsmotor war 2022 der
private Konsum der trotz der
rekordinflation Anstieg
und die Gesetze um die gesetzliche Rente
zu sichern will die Bundesregierung
künftig neue Wege gehen erstmals soll es
zusätzlich eine aktienrente in
Deutschland geben die Details dazu hat
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner heute
vorgestellt und das wollen wir uns noch
mal genauer anschauen mit Frank Bethmann
Frank wie soll das genau funktionieren
Herr Lindner will dafür einen staatsfon
lassen und den in den sollen nach seinen
Vorstellungen in den kommenden Jahren
über den Bundeshaushalt bis zu 150
Milliarden Euro fließen diese Gelder
werden nach und nach an den weltweiten
Aktienmärkten angelegt die Erträge
daraus die sollen später einmal einen
Beitrag zur Finanzierung der
gesetzlichen Rente beisteuern denn wenn
eine sicher ist dann dass die Löcher in
der Rentenkasse immer größer werden
immer weniger arbeitende müssen immer
mehr Rentner versorgen bereits im
abgelaufenen Jahren musste der Bund über
100 Milliarden Euro an Steuergeldern in
die Rentenkasse schießen und diese
Fehlbeträge werden größer
das braucht also dringend neue
Finanzierungsquellen wie lange dauert es
denn etwa bis so eine aktienrente
wirklich entlassen kann ja das hilft
nicht gleich morgen erstmal muss der
Kapitalstock ja aufgebaut werden Lindner
sagte heute selbst wir fangen erst mal
mit 10 Milliarden Euro an es muss dann
aber jedes Jahr neue politisch
entschieden werden stocken wir um
weitere 10 Milliarden auf und frühestens
ab Ende der 2030er Jahre wäre es im
besten Falle überhaupt sinnvoll Gelder
aus diesem Aktienfonds abzuziehen und
sollten trotz der langfristigen
Ausrichtung doch mal Verluste entstehen
betonte Lindner heute noch würde der
Staat im Zweifel mit einem
Bundeszuschuss spricht mit Steuergeldern
wie bisher auch einspringen vielen Dank
Frank für diese Einordnungen
das europäische Festland hat nun einen
eigenen Weltraumbahnhof und zwar in
Schweden nach jahrelangen Vorbereitungen
wurde im Norden des Landes der Spaceport
as Range feierlich eingeweiht von hier
aus sollen künftig vor allem Satelliten
ins All geschossen werden an der
Eröffnung nahm neben dem schwedischen
König auch
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
teil
zum Sport und damit zum erfolgreichen
Auftakt der Handball-WM für die deutsche
Nationalmannschaft mit einem Sieg gegen
Asienmeister Katha hat das Team von
Bundestrainer Gislason die erste Hürde
Richtung Hauptrunde genommen
Deutschland beginnt das Spiel gegen
Katha konzentriert und ist die bessere
Mannschaft ein starker Andreas Wolf im
Tor und viele Ballgewinne in der Abwehr
ermöglichen schnelle Tore 5 Mal trifft
Deutschland in der ersten Hälfte per
Tempo Gegenstoß wie hier der deutsche
wm-rekordspieler Patrick
bester Mann im DHB-Team heute einmal
mehr Jogi Knorr der Junge Spielmacher
hat viele gute Ideen und es mit acht
Toren bester Torschütze der Partie der
große Vorsprung ist in der zweiten
Hälfte relativ schnell dahin auch bei
Deutschland in der Deckung schwächelt
mit diesem Tor kommt Kata auf einen
Treffer an
aber wenn es drauf ankommt ist
Deutschland wieder da wie hier Yannick
Kohlbacher der sich am Kreis durchsetzt
einziger Wermutstropfen Andreas Wolf
verletzt sich bei seiner 15 Parade kurz
vor Schluss leicht an der Wade und
humpelt vom Platz 31 zu 27 gewinnt
Deutschland diesen Auftrag gegen Katar
und verschafft sich eine gute
Ausgangslage für das nächste Spiel gegen
Serbien dann hoffentlich wieder mit
torita Wolf
so ist es und so viel von uns wir
wünschen einen angenehmen Abend und
übergeben ans Politbarometer mit
Matthias Vorlauf tschüss
guten Abend willkommen zum
Politbarometer
Besetzung und Räumung der Streit um den
kleinen von seinen Anwohnern längst
verlassenen Ort lützerath hat
Symbolkraft die einen glauben fest daran
dass keine weitere Kohle abgebaut und
verfeuert werden darf wenn das 1,5 Grad
Ziel des Pariser Klimaabkommens erreicht
werden soll andere betonen dass man die
Kohle für die Energiesicherheit dringend
das zur Sicherung der Stromversorgung
klimaschädliche Kohlekraftwerke wieder
stärker genutzt werden finden 60 Prozent
der Befragten im Politbarometer richtig
36 Prozent sind dagegen doch das dafür
braun kohleabbaugebiete wie das bei
lützerath ausgeweitet werden will nur
ein Drittel der Befragten
59% lehnen das ab
das Comeback von Kohle und Öl durch
kreuzt die deutschen Klimaziele der
Ausbau von Wind und Sonne dauert länger
als vorgesehen 58 Prozent der Befragten
finden die Bundesregierung tue zu wenig
für den Klimaschutz der ist eben nur
eine von vielen Herausforderungen für
die Politik Ukraine Krieg
energie-koalition vor allem mit
Krisenmanagement beschäftigt
53 Prozent finden dass die
Bundesregierung ihre Arbeit eher gut
macht einen Durchschnitt der letzten
Jahre bescheidener Wert 41 Prozent
bewerten sie mit eher schlecht das eine
unionsgeführte Regierung ist besser
machen würde erwarten allerdings nur 21
Prozent fast jeder zweite denkt da gäbe
es keinen Unterschied und 24% glauben es
würde schlechter
ein eher mittelmäßiges Zeugnis also für
die Bundesregierung die
Opposition kann davon allerdings kaum
profitieren wenn am Sonntag
Bundestagswahl wäre gerne die SPD
unverändert auf 20 Prozent
CDU CSU auf 27 - 1 die Grünen 21 Prozent
plus eins die FDP unverändert 6 Prozent
AFD 14 - 1 und die Linke 6 plus 1
damit hätte die Ampel weiter keine
parlamentarische Mehrheit reichen würde
es aber für Schwarz-Grün
unsere Liste der wichtigsten
Politikerinnen und Politiker ist von den
Befragten neu bestimmt worden nicht mehr
dabei ist Christine Lambrecht erstmals
dabei innenministerinnen Nancy fäser auf
der Skala von +5 bis -5 bewertet nach
Sympathie und Leistung bleibt Alice
Weidel Schlusslicht unverändert mit
extrem negativen -2,7
Sahra Wagenknecht -0,7 verbessert
Platz 8 Friedrich Merz -0,4 unverändert
davor Christian Lindner minus 0,3
deutliche Verluste Nancy Fräser minus
0,1 Platz 5 für Markus Söder 0,0 Karl
Lauterbach 0,2 beide etwas besser
auf dem dritten Platz Olaf Scholz 0,5
leicht verschlechtert Platz 2 Annalena
baerbock unverändert mit 0,9 und ganz
vorne jetzt Robert Habeck 1,0 verbessert
eine große Mehrheit der Befragten
wünscht sich dass die Ukraine
unterstützt wird aber wie weit sollte
das gehen seit Monaten bittet um die
Lieferung von schützen und Kampfpanzern
40 Schützenpanzer Marder sollen nun
kommen die Entscheidung dazu ist
gefallen und die findet eine klare
Mehrheit gut noch nicht gefallen ist die
Entscheidung moderne Kampfpanzer wie den
Leopard 2 zu liefern hier zeigt sich
auch ein gespaltenes Meinungsbild
Deutschland soll den Leopard 2 in die
Ukraine liefern sagen 42 Prozent 46
Prozent wollen das nicht dafür sind vor
allem die Anhänger von Grünen und FDP
die der Linken und der AFD lehnen das
deutlich ab
Verteidigungsministerin Christine
Lambrecht steht seit Monaten in der
Kritik zuletzt wegen ihres umstrittenen
silvester-videos die Union bezweifelt
ihre Eignung fürs Amt und fordert seit
Wochen ihren Rücktritt
sie sollte zurücktreten sagen 60 Prozent
nur 25 Prozent wollen dass sie im Amt
bleibt sogar jede Art zweite
SPD-Anhänger fordert sie sollte gehen
die Strom und Gaspreise sinken aktuell
die Gasspeicher sind gut gefüllt die
Inflation leicht rückläufig zwar sieht
eine Mehrheit die wirtschaftliche Lage
in Deutschland immer noch kritisch aber
der persönliche Ausblick der deutschen
auf ihre eigene wirtschaftliche Lage ist
verhalten optimistisch
13% erwarten in einem Jahr besser
dazustehen als heute
58% glauben dass es keine großen
Veränderungen geben wird
das ist schlechter wird befürchten 27%
der Deutschen im Dezember waren es noch
35%
das war unser Bericht über die Stimmung
im Land die Grafiken und alle
Informationen zu unseren Umfragen finden
Sie wie immer im ZDF Text ab Seite 165
in der ZDF heute App und auf ZDF
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
Umfragen der Forschungsgruppe waren
Zustandekommen Informationen zur
Methodik und zu den Qualitätsstandards
finden Sie unter politbarometer.zdf.de
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse das
nächste Politbarometer gibt es dann am
27 Januar nach dem Wetter geht es hier
gleich weiter mit Aspekte Parallelwelten
was ist Realität
Ihnen noch einen entspannten Abend auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
jetzt ab in der Nacht gibt es eine
Wetterberuhigung das neue tief Frederick
steht aber schon vor der Tür und
beschert uns ein stürmisches und vor
allem nasses-wochenende so können
verbreitet um 15 Liter pro Quadratmeter
Regen bis Sonntagabend fallen im
weststau der Mittelgebirge also im
Bergischen Land über das hessische
Bergland bis zum Bayerischen Wald sind
aber bis 50 im Schwarz sogar Schwarzwald
sogar bis 60 Liter Regen pro
Quadratmeter möglich und im Verlauf der
letzten Woche hat es ja hier auch schon
viel geregnet das bedeutet kleinere
Überflutungen sind weiterhin möglich
jetzt heute Nacht klingen die Schauer
aber erstmal ab vorher bringen sie in
den Alpen oder im Bayerischen Wald
oberhalb von 800 Metern noch mal etwas
Schnee der in Kombination mit der
Temperatur hier zwischen -2 und zwei
Grad Lokal für Glätte sorgen kann
ansonsten erreichen wir vier bis sieben
Grad in der Nacht morgen sind es meist
sechs bis zehn Grad zweistellig und
damit milder ist es vor allem im Westen
mit 12 Grad ja morgen Vormittag ist es
im Osten zunächst noch aufgel bewölkt im
Westen stellt sich aber dann schon der
Dauerregen ein der sich im Tagesverlauf
nach Osten ausbreitet und auch der Wind
der in der Nacht etwas nachgelassen hat
frischt von West nach Ost auf an der
Nordsee und im Bergland sind schwere
Sturmböen möglich ja und am Sonntag
verstärkt sich der Wind im Norden sogar
noch mal mit Orkanböen an der See und
die Schneefallgrenze singt am
Montagvormittag sind oberhalb von 200
bis 400 Metern sogar über 10 cm
Neuschnee drin am Dienstag wird es noch
mal etwas kälter also es wird nächste
Woche in den Bergland sogar eine
winterliche Woche tschüss